les ukrainiens naissance nombreux nous
sommes des millions
et nous avons des millions de
possibilités de lutter pour notre avenir
2 pour notre pays et pour notre
liberté pour notre drapeau drapeau bleu
et jaune à nous le défendons parce que
c'est notre vision notre vision qui
s'apparente à un autre drapeau
nous en sommes et dans l'espace nous
sommes et dans l'antarctique
nous sommes en sauveteurs des médecins
des sapeurs-pompiers tous ceux qui ont
aidé israël et la grèce la géorgie
l'afghanistan monténégro l'italie contre
le congo its d'autres d'autres pays dans
le monde entier
ce qui non nous avons
ce qui nous nous avons jamais fait nous
n'avons jamais envahi
des terres des autres nous n'avons
jamais tuer des gens des civils des
peuples différents
ainsi notre drapeau n'est pas tâche et
nous sommes notre drapeau n'aura jamais
de croix gammées l'ukraine ce sont des
terres des terres fertiles l'ukraine
c'est en ciel ciel dégagé bleus 100
roquettes et missiles ç'a toujours été
comme cela et ce sera toujours comme
cela je le sais gloire à le clan